both The Associated Press news agency in
the Reuters news agency in the last few
moments have given us some quite
stunning breaking news arkady bob chenko
the russian journalist who was reported
to be killed in kiev has shown up at a
news conference in ukraine and mr. bob
chenko says that this is an operation
that had been prepared for two months
and he thanks the ukrainian security
service for saving his life at the head
of the ukrainian security services has
said that they received information
about a Russian plan to assassinate mr.
Bob chenko and they managed to prevent
it and they've confirmed that mr. Bob
chenko is alive a Ukrainian citizen in
connection with mr. Bob Jenkins supposed
murder has been detained and this
citizen was also asked to buy weapons
and ammunition it's a very confusing
picture at this point in time and but as
far as we're aware confirmed by by two
news agencies the Russian journalists on
your screen arkady bob Schenker who was
reported killed in kiev has shown up at
a news conference in ukraine I suppose
the implication that this was a sting
operation mr. Bob chenko still speaking
at the moment saying he apologizes for
what people have gone through and he's
speaking at this live televised briefing
by the Ukrainian security service and
Jamieson it's it's good that you're here
with us
you were immediate reaction to this well
my media reaction is it's great news
that he's alive but this is the Russian
modus operandi they kill people in other
countries they they killed Litvinenko
they tried to kill scribble and they
also try to extradite anybody they can
so that they can imprison them and
silence them which is what they've been
doing to mr. Browder and this is the
kind of behavior that we have to take
action to prevent so explain explain
what is happening with mr. Bob chenko
here it's doesn't why he's a
anti-russian journalist and writer
obviously he's been in Ukraine the
Ukrainian security services as far as
we're aware knew of a plot to kill him
but they've they've done a sting
operation instead why well first of all
I know as much as yeah
but but of course look if it's true I I
wanted to catch whoever was out there to
go kill him in the act so we'll find out
what happened but it seems like thank
God they had advanced information and
prevented a murder